In the first problem of the exam, we wrote
a lexer for a new programming language. In the
second problem, we're going to write a parser that
will create an abstract syntax tree for something similar to
the listening tuples that we find in pie-pon. We're
only going to consider numbers, but we are going to
recognize the difference between a list that has brackets
and a tuple that has parentheses. So in our parser,
we have expressions. And let's say an expression can be a number, a list of
expressions and lastly a tuple of expressions.
So let's start off with numbers. Here's our
parsing rule for the number expression. We simply take in the number and put it
in tuple where the first element is the
type following our convention in our web browser,
and our second element is going to be the
value. So, here I've written up the function for
Tuple expressions. We have a left parenthesis, this new
thing, called expcomma and then a right parenthesis. So basically
a tuple surrounded by parentheses. Here, I haven't defined
this yet. And what this is going to be
is going to be a sequence of expressions where
there is a comma separating each expression. We'll define that
last and we'll also be using it in the list
expression. Here, I have a special rule that takes care
of the case, just a single expressions surrounded by parentheses.
In reality, we want our language to take this as
just an expression, which is what happens in python. In
python, if you wanted to make this a tuple, a
tuple of one element, you have to add a comma.
Otherwise, we're going to set this element in our abstract syndextry
to be a tuple, where the first element is
the string tuple, followed by the value. Here's my
function for the list expression. It's a going to
be expcomma, which is. That construct right up here
surrounded by brackets. And we don't have the special
case that we had right here because we want
our language to have singleton less. So we want
the character a, or, I guess since we have just
numbers, five, to be an out list. This is not the same
idea as doing. Five surrounded by parentheses, we want that just to
be five. So we have the basics here, let's just go to
the code to finish it up. So here we have the problem description.
And I've filled in the solution. We have the number expressions, the tuple
and the list which are unchanged from what I did. But I've also added
the expression comma where an expression
comma is an expression, a comma. Followed
by an expression comma, where an expression
comma can also be just an expression.